il
le maloya de firmin viry qui résonne
dans une classe du collège de terre
sainte
c'est la récompense offerte par le
chantre du maloya la jeune génération
c'est dans le cadre des collèges en
musique que cette fabuleuse rencontre a
pu se faire d'un côté firmin viry celui
qui a connu le maloya marot et de
l'autre deux jeunes adolescents qui
connaissent peu le maloya chanter en
liberté firmin viry fiers aujourd'hui de
rencontrer ces collégiens pour
transmettre sa musique sa culture et
surtout son patrimoine
c'est un honneur pour moi parce que deby
me croyais pas si ça a atteint dimanche
à la classe populaire et puis ensuite il
n'est pas obligé et mechal qu'il est
certain jules d'enfants mais du mal qui
précédemment
ces nus d'identité après avoir un moment
rapporte année pendant neuf mois
elle venait naissance j'ai pas vu des
cas nous on état civil est semaine à pau
tout le monde y un mois après pour avoir
ni l'identité ni l'identité à poings nus
l'identité c'est notre culture que ledit
accroché direct partager un moment
unique en échangeant avec firmin viry ce
fut aussi l'occasion de chanter de jouer
du maloya avec lui à l'image de davy
très fier d'avoir participé à cet
atelier
ça c'est bien se passer on a beaucoup
discuté sur le maloya
depuis que je suis petit je cognais le
maloya et je suis parti à plusieurs de
ses concerts un moment inscrit dans le
parcours pédagogique de ces collégiens
puisque désormais c'est la connaissance
de la culture et du maloya sont reconnus
comme de vraies richesses au sein de
l'enseignement scolaire aujourd'hui
il est important pour les élèves dans
leur parcours pédagogique de rencontrer
la culture et de faire connaissance avec
les applis qui représente la réunion
aujourd'hui nous accueillons firmin viry
et du fortuné au collège terre sainte
est un immense plaisir et un grand
honneur et donc oui c'est indispensable
pour que les élèves puissent connaître
cette culture millénaire qui est la leur
et vous aussi partagez les valeurs tous
ensemble toutes les générations
confondues
firmin viry et jim fortuné les invités
prestigieux qui ont permis à ces
collégiens de côtoyer au plus près le
maloya et l'histoire du maloya
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle rencontre tout aussi
enrichissante